寝起き過ぎてヤバいな
(ｺｫｫｯｹｯｺｫｫｯｗｗｗ↑)
おはようございます。はじめしゃちょーです
(ｫｯｺｫｫｫｫｗｗｗｗｗ↑)
あのー…僕、ちょいちょいヘンなYouTuberが
家に来るんですよ。
どっちかというとね、有名というか後輩ですね！
後輩のYouTuberがちょいちょい家に来るんですけども
あー、もうすぐ… もうすぐ着くな
後輩YouTuberが今から家に来るんですけども
みなさんご存じのとおり
僕、今、
禁止してます。
禁止してるんで、そのマジな方で、あのー
本当だからね (大事なことなので復唱)
本当にお菓子、ジュースまったく食べてないし
飲んでもないんですけど
やっぱり..... 裏で........
飲んでそうじゃないすか (？)
いや、飲んでないけどね？ (迫真)
飲んでないよ (2回目)
飲んでないけど、(3回目)
実際なんか「裏で飲んでそうだな」って
よく言われるんですけども
まさきとかいろんな後輩にも
見てもらってるんですけれども
ほんとに飲んでないんですけども、
今から来る後輩YouTuberが
もし仮に、
どういう顔をするのかってゆうね、
ちょっと検証していきたいと思います。
一応準備しました。空のコーラです
俺飲んでないからね！！ (しつこい)
いかにコーラを飲まずにこの色まで近づけるか？
っていうことまでしなきゃいけません。
黒(こく)烏龍茶とブラックコーヒーがあれば
たぶん何かできそうと思ったので
やべえ寝起きだ… テンション上げていこう
ﾊﾟﾝｯ↑
ｳﾜｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｱｯｗｗｗｗ
(やべぇ...)
(痛ぇ。)
この色に近づけます
いや、飲んでそうってよく言われるんですよね
(友A) 実はコッソリ飲んでるでしょう？
(友B) いやいやー絶対飲んでるでしょ！
って、いろんな人に言われるんですけど
断じて飲んでないから
そんなつまらないことをすると
来年？ その時のね、
食べたときのリアクションが薄くなるから
あれもう結構((ｱﾗﾗｰｼｬｯｗｗ
もうブラックコーヒーだけで結構いい線
いくんじゃないこれ
あー割といい線行ってるな
お！かも、え、待ってほんとに同じじゃない？
コーラと比べてちょっと濃いんで
ちょっと黒(こく)烏龍茶いれて
わかんないっしょこれ！
完全に一緒！
色的にはほぼ完全に一緒ですね
あの、今回の見どころは多分なんですけども
その (？)
僕がコーラを飲んでいる顔を見た後の
後輩の顔の表情とかが
どんな顔なのｶﾅｧｧｯ////
ってのが知りたくてやってみようと思います
不味いゼ☆
では行こう！
はい…
あ、そうっすね～ (演技)
はい (⤴︎)
はい (⤵︎)
あ～なるほどなるほど (謎の理解)
はい (生返事)
あ～なるほど (←わかってない)
なるほど、ということはチャンネルを削除す... (←失言)
あっ、アッー！(絶頂感)
〈後輩〉お疲れ様です。(大真面目)
〈は〉うん (事後)
〈は〉あー、なるほど (虚無感)
〈は〉はい (再起動)
〈後〉ｳｪｯ (突然の吐き気)
〈は〉はい (若干の萎え)
〈は〉(ﾁﾗｯ)
〈後〉(あ… 生はじめんだ)
〈は〉(あ… 気づいてない)
〈は〉遊戯王カードｗ
〈後〉遊戯、あっ…(察し)
〈後〉あ、ﾌｧｲ
はい (キレ気味)
あっサーセン、はい (←反省してない)
(なんで気付かないんだよ！ｳｫｲｯ↑)
(これじゃ企画が台無しだよ！ｳｫｲｯ↑)
(ｯｯｯｯﾏｯ↑↑↑)
〈は〉もしもしまさきー？
〈は〉今ちょうどアレだよ
〈は〉つる兄(後輩)が来てるよ
〈は〉ｱｯー! ありがとありがとありがと
〈つ〉これで大丈夫ですか？
〈は〉うんっ
〈は〉ｱｯー! ちょっ、まさき替わろうか？ つる兄に
〈は〉はい (←彼女取られた感)
〈つ〉もしもしィ⤴︎ (チャラ男風)
〈つ〉はじめましてｗ (出会い厨)
〈つ〉どうもでｨーす (チャラ男風)
〈つ〉なっ、何話せばいいんですか？(コミュ症)
〈つ〉ﾏｯ… (コミュ症)
〈つ〉１､２本... まぁ１本くらいは、
撮りたいなーみたいな (←出まかせ)
〈つ〉ｳｨｯｽ/// (←性の目覚め)
〈は〉(気づけ)
〈は〉(気づけコラ)
〈つ〉絶対寝起きですよね？ (間違ってたらｽﾏｿ)
〈つ〉ﾌﾌﾌﾌｯ//// (←おネエの覚醒)
〈は〉(そこじゃねーよアホ)
〈つ〉(察し)
〈つ〉ﾌｯﾊﾊｯｗ
〈は〉普通にバレちゃったわ。(アホかこいつ)
〈つ〉ﾊﾊﾊﾊﾊｯｗｗ (←信じられない)
〈つ〉ﾊﾊﾊｯｗｗ (←現実逃避)
〈つ〉ええぇｗ (←事実確認)
〈は〉やべやべやべｗ (やばいとは言ってない)
〈は〉バレちゃったｗ (何もバレてない)
〈つ〉ｲﾔｧｧ.....まぁ、
〈つ〉(ザ ･ 適当)
〈つ〉(キング ･ オブ ･ 適当)
〈つ〉(レジェンド ･ オブ ･ 適当)
〈は〉ﾌﾞﾌｫｯｗ (不意打ち)
〈つ〉ｴｪｲﾌﾎﾊﾋﾔｗｗｗｗ (錯乱)
〈つ〉えぇ....(混乱)
〈つ〉言ってもいいですか？ (←スピーカー)
〈は〉あぁ、まさきは知ってる (アホだこいつ)
〈つ〉あぁ↑あぁ↓ (わかったつもり)
〈つ〉いや、コカ・コーラを平然と飲んでたんでｗ
(↑ 事実を述べただけ)
〈つ〉ｴﾌﾎﾍｯｗｗｗｗ (混濁)
〈つ〉えー、流石に無理でしたか一年は (記者かぶれ)
〈つ〉ｱﾊﾊﾊｯｗｗ (笑うしかない)
〈は〉だってもうお菓子無いと無理じゃん (本音)
〈つ〉そうですね()
〈は〉あぁ流石に一年は無理だったなぁ...(ガチ)
〈つ〉(ゲス顔)
〈つ〉(ゲス顔・どアップ)
〈つ〉(ゲス顔・映す価値なし)
〈は〉バレちゃったんだけどコーラ飲んでるｗｗってｗｗｗ
〈は〉どうしよう
〈ま〉(←おネエ全開)
〈は〉ﾂｲｯﾃｰ(？)
〈は〉ツイートしないでほんとに (←雑な演技)
〈つ〉しないですよしないですよ！(マジレス)
〈つ〉しないしないしないしない！(必死)
〈つ〉絶対絶対しない！(しないとは言ってない)
〈は〉ほんとにとんt@*?"#&). (←ヤケクソ)
〈は〉あー元気だったかつる兄。(話題転換)
〈つ〉いやぁ...(コーラｗ)
〈つ〉元気ですよー(適当)
〈つ〉まぁ元気ですけども (コーラ...)
〈つ〉バイトやめて、(コーラ...)
〈は〉えっ
〈つ〉`:@3#(&?//.,:;
（Youtube...）
〈は〉えっ、何やってんの今？ (うわニートかよ)
〈つ〉いやちょっと
〈つ〉お金と時間に困ってるんだなー分かった！みたいな(？)
〈つ〉対処法を考えるって言われて、今、僕、
〈つ〉(大人の事情で聞かせられないナイショな話)
〈は〉えぇっ (相当ヤバかったらしい)
〈は〉今動画とってるよｗｗ (ネタバラシしとこｗ)
〈つ〉えぇっ！？ (←素)
〈は〉ほらそこもｗ
〈つ〉ちょちょちょｗｗ
〈は〉ﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊｯﾊwwww
〈つ〉えぇっ、コレえぇっコレっ！？
〈つ〉これ駄目ｗ
ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑ﾃﾞ↓ﾃﾞ↑
（いつもの）
（エンディング）
ﾃﾞｰ　ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞｰﾃﾞｰ
ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰ　ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰﾃﾞｰ
ﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾞｰ　ﾃﾞｰﾚﾚ
ﾃﾞﾚﾚﾚｰﾚｰﾚｰ（ﾝﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞﾝﾃﾞ）
（今回は「ﾃﾞ」でお送りしました）
ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟ・ﾍﾟﾝ☆
（突然の「ﾍﾟ」）
（もうちょっと続くよ！）
〈は〉はい、という訳で今回の動画は、
「はじめしゃちょーがコーラを飲んでいたら」
ドッキリでしたー！！
〈つ〉えぇっ！？
〈は〉飲んでみ？
〈つ〉ｱｲﾋｯﾋｨｗｗｗ↑↑ (即絶頂)
〈つ〉にっっがぁ！！ (←液の感想)
〈つ〉うわぁ、まじでちょっと一瞬、あー
見てしまったー(気まずい) みたいなｗ
〈つ〉ｗｗｗｗｗｗ (笑うしかない)
〈は〉俺がコーラを飲むと思ったか！！ｗ
〈つ〉ぇ、ちょっ、ちょっと。(本音)
〈つ〉ｗｗｗｗ (←失礼を紛らわす)
〈は〉いや皆そう言うんだよねぇ...(´・ω・` )